so what is a habit and I think the key
thing about a habit really comes down to
decision-making because sometimes people
think about it's something that you do
repeatedly you know it unfolds over time
but really the key thing about a habit
is that you're not making a decision
you're not deciding whether to brush
your teeth you're not deciding whether
to use a seat belt you're not deciding
whether to go to the gym first thing in
the morning you've already decided and
the advantage of a habit is that once
something's on automatic pilot then the
brain doesn't have to use any energy or
willpower to make a decision you've
already made that decision you're just
moving forward and so it happens easily
without any thought without any
willpower with any without any effort
you're just on cruise control and then
you can do what you want to get done how
that is like the invisible architecture
of everyday life research shows that
something like 40% of what we do every
day we do in pretty much the same way
and in the same context so it's easy to
see that if you have habits that work
for you you're much more likely to be
happier healthy and more productive if
you have habits that don't work for you
it's really going to drag you down
because it's a big part of our days is
taken up by habits one of the mysteries
of habits is why do we persist in having
bad habits when we know they're not good
for us when they know they don't make us
happy but you know there's usually
multiple things going maybe it's what
you want right this minute versus what
you want on the long term or maybe you
want to things that are in conflict on
the one hand you want to have plenty of
time to hang out and goof around on the
other hand you want to have a clean
Pleasant apartment so you have two
things that are in conflict so when you
have a bad habit it's very helpful to
think very clearly what do I really want
over the long term what's what's really
most important to me and that can help
you fight back against the pull that
gravitational pull that a bad habit can
exert one of the things people say about
habit sometimes is they're like make
healthy choices and I completely
disagree don't make healthy choices make
one healthy choice and then no more
deciding the reason that habits can can
give us so much more power in our lives
is that they eliminate the need for
decision making you can just decide one
time what you're going to do and then
you don't revisit that decision because
every time we make a decision we have
the opportunity to decide wrong
and even if we decide correctly we still
are using a lot of energy to battle with
that decision so you really want to use
decision-making to set out a habit that
you want and maybe to anticipate a lot
of the challenges a lot of the stumbling
blocks that you might encounter along
the way is you're trying to form that
habit but once you've made that decision
don't look back
decide wants and then no more deciding
one question is whether you're better
off trying to do one habit at a time if
you're trying to make change or whether
you do many all at once and like many
things that have information there's
just no magic answer there's no
one-size-fits-all solution some people
do better when they start small when
they keep it very simple and they gain
the habit of the habit they get a
feeling of accomplishment and it's very
manageable and realistic cuz it's
something very small and it's just like
one thing but on the other hand there's
some people who love to go big that look
big transformations and big challenges
and so something to do is to think about
yourself and think well what do I
succeeded in the past or what appeals
more to my nature and you think about
what works for you because there really
isn't one perfect way to change a habit
or to change a bunch of habits it really
depends on what's going to work for you